This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The best knockoffs in the world are in China. Sure, designer handbags and Rolexes, but also really large-scale imitations. Like fake Apple stores that are so dead on that employees of the store think they're working in a real Apple store. But beyond just working in knockoffs, many residents of Chinese suburbs live their lives in replica cities, vennices with complete canals and replicas of the Doge's Palace, parisists with rifle towers and arc to tree alps. They're Chrysler buildings, Sydney Opera houses.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。世界上最好的仿制品都在中国。当然，不仅是名牌手袋和劳力士，还有非常大规模的仿造。比如那些极其逼真的假苹果商店，连店员都以为自己在真正的苹果商店工作。但除了在仿制品中工作外，许多中国郊区的居民还生活在复制城市中，比如拥有完整运河和总督宫复制品的“威尼斯”，拥有埃菲尔铁塔和凯旋门的“巴黎”。还有克莱斯勒大厦和悉尼歌剧院。
Driving through the suburbs of any city in China, you will find a plethora of fake Versailles, British developments, and California is all bumping upside by side. Just Shanghai itself has ten cities all built in the architectural style of different European countries. So it's possible to travel from Germany to Italy to London in the course of a few hours provided there's not too much traffic. Bianca Boscher is the author of the book Original Copies, architectural mimicry in contemporary China, and she coined a term for these buildings. DupliTector. DupliTector refers to this nationwide movement taking place in China whereby people are copying entire cities and towns from Europe and the United States.
开车穿过中国任何城市的郊区，你会发现大量的假凡尔赛宫、英式开发项目和加州风格建筑并排矗立。仅上海就有十座完全按照不同欧洲国家建筑风格建造的城市。因此，只要交通不拥堵，几小时内就可以从德国“旅行”到意大利，再到伦敦。比安卡·博舍是《原始副本：当代中国的建筑模仿》一书的作者，她为这些建筑创造了一个术语：DupliTector（复制建筑）。DupliTector指的是中国全国范围内正在进行的这种运动，人们正在复制欧洲和美国的整个城市和城镇。
Life size, or sometimes even bigger than life size. These are not theme parks, dupletector developments are actually living breathing communities, where Chinese families are raising their children, living out their lives in a place that looks like Orange County or Paris, but a smack dab in the middle of the People's Republic. These buildings are not just novelty as like the pyramid or the Eiffel Tower in Las Vegas.
真人大小，有时甚至比真人还大。这些不是主题公园，复制建筑开发项目实际上是活生生的社区，中国家庭在这里抚养孩子，生活在看起来像奥兰治县或巴黎的地方，但却位于中华人民共和国的中心地带。这些建筑不仅仅是像拉斯维加斯的金字塔或埃菲尔铁塔那样的噱头。
The biggest private property developer in China told me that two-thirds of their residential developments were being built in a European style. Nor they like American Chinatownsowns, which were established by immigrants. These are Chinese communities in American or European-style buildings, which are often designed by Chinese architects. Visiting China's copy of Paris in the outskirts of Hangzhou, I found a place that in some ways was very emblematic of Paris. You had the Eiffel Tower, you had the Sh that it is a square, but there was no new architecture.
中国最大的私人房地产开发商告诉我，他们三分之二的住宅开发项目都是以欧洲风格建造的。它们也不像美国由移民建立的唐人街。这些是中国人在美式或欧式建筑中的社区，通常由中国建筑师设计。在杭州郊区参观中国的“巴黎”复制品时，我发现了一个在某些方面非常具有巴黎象征意义的地方。你有埃菲尔铁塔，你有香榭丽舍大街，但没有新的建筑。
Meaning the Chinese weren't interested in duplicating the newer buildings of Paris, just the old classic looking ones that are iconic of the city. At the same time, this is really the most brand new sparkling Paris I've ever seen. We've done all this, all the luxury, all the culture, all the people. sparkling Paris I've ever seen. Even though these are intended to be copies, it's pretty much impossible to plop a building
意思是说，中国人对复制巴黎的新建筑不感兴趣，只对那些标志性的老式经典建筑感兴趣。与此同时，这确实是我见过的最新、最闪亮的巴黎。我们完成了这一切，所有的奢华，所有的文化，所有的人。这是我见过的最闪亮的巴黎。尽管这些建筑旨在成为复制品，但几乎不可能将一座建筑
onto a completely new environment without modifying it a little, or a lot. Oftentimes the dupletecture is larger, or smaller than real thing, or different elements, or features might be loaded bigger than others, sometimes dupletecture gets so twisted and warped until it's a freakish caricature of the original. One of the interesting twists on this architectural movement has been the creation of mega-high rises that are built in a baroque or a neoclassical style. Picture Versailles stretched 20 floors into the air, and you'll have some idea of what's going on.
直接放置在一个全新的环境中而不进行一点或大量的修改。通常，复制建筑比实物更大或更小，或者不同的元素或特征可能比其他部分更突出，有时复制建筑会被扭曲和变形，直到成为原型的怪异讽刺画。这种建筑运动中一个有趣的转折是创造了巴洛克或新古典主义风格的超高层建筑。想象一下凡尔赛宫被拉高了20层，你就会对正在发生的事情有所了解。
Developers can take a lot of liberties with dupletexture construction, like making the replicas work in accordance with Feng Shui. But nevertheless, a lot of these dupletexture compounds have rules that actively discourage any type of modification that they think might subvert the some lacrum. They're very, very strict rules in place to ensure that Chinese elements or foreign elements don't crop in and spoil the impression of a Paris.
开发商在复制建筑施工中可以采取很多自由，比如让复制品符合风水。但尽管如此，许多这些复制建筑群都有规则，积极阻止任何他们认为可能破坏这种幻象的修改。他们有非常非常严格的规定，以确保中国元素或外国元素不会混入并破坏巴黎的印象。
And these rules have been set up to preserve the European feel of this development. For example, no hanging laundry outside, no changing the paint, no installing air conditioners, no keeping chickens in the backyard. To further create the impression of Paris, there might be a French bakery or a bestial day celebration. There might be a pub and an Irish town or a real canal network and a knockoff Venice.
这些规则是为了保持该开发项目的欧洲风情而制定的。例如，禁止在外面晾晒衣物，禁止改变油漆颜色，禁止安装空调，禁止在后院养鸡。为了进一步营造巴黎的印象，可能会有法式面包店或巴士底日庆祝活动。爱尔兰小镇可能会有酒吧，或者在仿制的威尼斯有真正的运河网络。
As odd and uncanny as these buildings and communities can be, dupletecture is pretty impressive. These buildings go up quickly on a massive scale and they show no signs of stopping. Boscow saw new developments popping up around China all the time, but dupletecture is not exactly a new trend. They have a lot of practice doing this. In pre-modern China, you had China's Imperial rulers using copycat buildings as a way of showing off their power and establishing their authority. On the 3rd century BC, one of the rulers showed off his conquest of the rival kingdom by recreating their buildings within his own capital city.
尽管这些建筑和社区可能显得古怪和离奇，但复制建筑确实令人印象深刻。这些建筑在大规模上迅速兴起，而且没有停止的迹象。博舍看到中国各地不断涌现新的开发项目，但复制建筑并不是什么新鲜趋势。他们在这方面有很多实践。在现代中国之前，中国的帝国统治者就使用仿造建筑作为炫耀权力和确立权威的一种方式。在公元前3世纪，一位统治者通过在自己的都城内重建敌国的建筑来炫耀他对敌国的征服。
You also had Imperial hunting parks where rulers would import flora and fauna of all kinds to recreate known landscapes within their own domain. These Imperial rulers would copy as a way of showing that they could literally move heaven and earth. They now possessed this foreign building or place it was theirs. And in keeping with that tradition, one of the most copied buildings in China is the very seat of Western power itself. The White House is generally credited as being the most copied building in China, and
你还有皇家狩猎公园，统治者会进口各种动植物，在自己的领地内重建已知的景观。这些帝国统治者通过复制来表明他们可以真正地移山填海。他们现在拥有了这座外国建筑或地方，它是他们的。为了延续这一传统，中国被复制最多的建筑之一正是西方权力的中心本身。白宫通常被认为是全中国被复制最多的建筑，并且
is used for everything from hotels to restaurants to court houses to homes. Just like the White House has a China collection, China has a White House collection. The different Chinese White House has served different purposes, so they've morphed into various permutations. But they all have those signature columns and square portico built in the True Blue Unique-style, wholly original to the US of A. I hate to break it to everyone, but that's not a original building. The architect who built the White House based his design on this huge building in Dublin that is now the seat of the Parliament of Ireland. The Linstra House in Dublin, which in turn has elements of classical Greek and Roman architecture, and it pretty much looks like the White House, even though it's kind of grey.
被用于从酒店到餐厅、法院到住宅的各种用途。就像白宫有中国收藏一样，中国也有白宫收藏。不同的中国白宫服务于不同的目的，因此它们演变成了各种变体。但它们都有那些标志性的圆柱和方形门廊，以纯正的独特风格建造，完全原创于美国。我不忍心打破大家的幻想，但那并不是一座原创建筑。建造白宫的建筑师基于都柏林的一座巨大建筑设计，该建筑现在是爱尔兰议会的所在地。都柏林的伦斯特大厦，它本身具有古典希腊和罗马建筑的元素，而且它看起来和白宫很像，尽管它是灰色的。
This is the grey house. The founding fathers were really into dupletector as well. They were their own form of architectural plagiarists. And this is so obvious if you've ever seen the buildings that Thomas Jefferson designed. They're also covered in columns. He based the Virginia State Capitol on this ancient Roman temple, and that design in turn has gone on to influence the design of many, many state capitals around the country. Some of the greatest hits of American architecture are copies of the greatest hits of ancient Roman architecture, which are now all being copied by the Chinese. So we did it too. And North America was ruled by Europeans, so it makes sense that we would have more European-style architecture lying around.
这就是灰色大厦。开国元勋们也非常热衷于复制建筑。他们有自己形式的建筑剽窃。如果你见过托马斯·杰斐逊设计的建筑，这一点就很明显。它们也覆盖着圆柱。他以这座古罗马神庙为基础设计了弗吉尼亚州议会大厦，而该设计反过来又影响了全国许多州议会大厦的设计。一些美国建筑的“热门金曲”是古罗马建筑“热门金曲”的复制品，而现在这些又都被中国人复制了。所以我们也这样做过。而且北美曾被欧洲人统治，所以我们周围有更多的欧洲风格建筑也就不足为奇了。
But we still continue to build these European homages today. When Americans build MacMansions or buildings that draw from European elements, we're being inspired. When the Chinese do so, they're ripping off, they're copying, they're con artists. And I think that's unfair. We should all recognize that what we're all doing is copying some pretty old buildings
但我们今天仍然继续建造这些欧洲风格的致敬之作。当美国人建造麦克豪宅或借鉴欧洲元素的建筑时，我们是在寻找灵感。当中国人这样做时，他们就是在剽窃，在抄袭，是骗子。我认为这不公平。我们都应该认识到，我们所做的都是在复制一些非常古老的建筑，
because we still find them attractive and we still think that they have symbolic significance to our everyday lives. It's easy to scoff at knockoffs of Venice, but these warped memories are the start of something new. I say this all the time. Stealing plus lack of talent equals creativity. What I mean there is that in the effort to copy something, your skills or lack of skills or your different experience, it mutates the original. So that very often, you come up with something that's completely new and completely yours.
因为我们仍然觉得它们很有吸引力，并且仍然认为它们对我们的日常生活具有象征意义。嘲笑威尼斯的仿制品很容易，但这些扭曲的记忆是新事物的开始。我经常说：偷窃加上缺乏天赋等于创造力。我的意思是，在努力复制某样东西的过程中，你的技能、缺乏技能或不同的经验会使原型发生变异。因此，你经常会想出一些全新的、完全属于你自己的东西。
Copying is totally underrated and mindful iteration is how good things become great things. China has actually proven quite successful at turning copies into innovation. If you look at the Shanghai movement in China, which is this name given for copies of the iPhone, of sneakers, of social networks, what you find is that oftentimes the copies actually improve on the original in certain ways. China's iPhone knockoff, which I believe is called the siphon, actually had some features that you couldn't find on Apple's phone. You had removable battery, you had multiple SIM cards,
复制被完全低估了，有意识的迭代是好东西变成伟大东西的方式。中国实际上已经证明在将复制品转化为创新方面非常成功。如果你看看中国的上海运动，也就是对iPhone、运动鞋、社交网络的复制，你会发现，通常这些复制品实际上在某些方面改进了原型。中国的iPhone仿制品，我相信叫“siphon”，实际上有一些你在苹果手机上找不到的功能。你有可拆卸电池，你有多个SIM卡，
all of these things that Apple users actually really wanted and coveted. And here you could find it in this knock-off phone. I'm personally fascinated to see how China takes its imitation and turns it into innovation. The Business. Wow! You copy me! Hey, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, was produced this week by Avery Troubleman of Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced of the offices of Arxine, a comprehensive architectural firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Speaking of our dear East Bay, yours truly was named Best Local Radio Host and the Best of the East Bay Edition of the
所有这些都是苹果用户真正想要和渴望的东西。在这里，你可以在这款仿制手机中找到它。我个人很着迷于观察中国如何将其模仿转化为创新。《商业》节目。哇！你抄袭我！嘿，你……本周由艾弗里·特鲁布尔曼、凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，并在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心Arxine建筑事务所的办公室制作。说到我们亲爱的东湾，本人在《东湾快报》的“东湾最佳”版中被评为最佳本地广播主持人。
East Bay Express. That totally made my day. Thanks guys. The 99PI experience isn't just this episode that you're hearing, we're also fascinating on Twitter. You can follow us at RomanMarr, SamListens, KatieMingle, and Troubleman. We're also on Facebook, Tumblr, Instagram, Flickr, SoundCloud, and Spotify too. But our home on the web is 99PI.org. Radio Tapio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那真是让我的一天都变得美好了。谢谢大家。99PI体验不仅仅是你听到的这一集，我们在Twitter上也很有趣。你可以关注RomanMarr、SamListens、KatieMingle和Troubleman。我们也在Facebook、Tumblr、Instagram、Flickr、SoundCloud和Spotify上。但我们在网上的家是99PI.org。Radio Tapio。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。